CBS our parent company Paramount Global
and former CBS president and CEO Leslie
moonves have agreed to a settlement a
settlement worth more than 30 million
dollars to resolve allegations of
insider trading misleading investigators
and attempting to conceal sexual assault
claims seven and a quarter million of
that amount of money will be paid by
Paramount Global with the rest coming
from previous CBS agreements and two and
a half million will come from moonves
himself moonves you'll recall was fired
back in 2018 after harassment
allegations against him became public he
denied then and denies now any
wrongdoing our national correspondent
dreka Duncan has been following the
investigation since the very beginning
and she's here now with some new
information revealed in this
multi-million dollar settlement Eureka
good morning yeah a lot of money that
we're talking about good morning to
everyone in the course of this
investigation by New York State Attorney
General Leticia James she says that her
office uncovered that certain Executives
with CBS knew about the allegations
against moonves and James says that
cover-up started with a tip by one
high-ranking police officer in Los
Angeles
[Music]
president Leslie moonves and some of his
top Executives worked to cover up sexual
assault allegations against him before
they went public that's according to a
report by New York State's Attorney
General Leticia James James says CBS was
tipped off by now retired Los Angeles
police captain Corey palka who was part
of moonves security detail for years
during the Grammys according to the
report palka alerted a CBS executive
just hours after a woman filed a
complaint with police alleging that
moonves sexually assaulted her it says
palka even shared the woman's complaint
with some CBS Executives including
moonves and then consistently worked
with the group to keep the allegations
hidden in one text according to the
report moonves wrote to palka hopefully
we can kill media from PD then figure
what complaintant number one wants
more allegations of assault and
harassment by multiple women against
moonves were published months later he
was fired from CBS in September of 2018.
James's report also alleged insider
trading stating that one senior
executive who knew of the police
investigation in Los Angeles sold more
than eight million dollars worth of CBS
stock before the allegations against
moonves could become public in a
statement after announcing a 30.5
million dollar settlement had been
reached James said CBS failed its most
basic duty to be honest and transparent
with the public and investors the
majority of the settlement will be paid
to shareholders
cbs's parent company Paramount Global
said in a statement it is pleased to
resolve this matter without any
admission of liability or wrongdoing
adding it does not relate in any way to
the current company the LAPD said it's
cooperating with investigations and
started an internal investigation into
any further wrongdoing we have reached
out to that retired officer but have not
heard back and attorneys for moonves did
not respond to us for comment but
moonves has previously denied the
allegations against him and he still
denies those allegations it's always
awkward and uncomfortable and I think
embarrassing to report about you know
alleged wrong doing a wrongdoing against
a company that you work for and we also
work for I think it's also important to
point out that we have new management
here but this is very difficult to hear
yeah very difficulty the connection
between that prior uh company and this
one it doesn't exist anymore exactly
tarika thank you thank you